Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris
it's a perfect game
[Laughter]
that was the most beautiful thing I'd
ever seen
[Music]
I played for five minutes
still see falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
[Music]
it's the perfect game Tetris Tetris
Tetris Tetris Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Martian
Adventure he likes tennis
this game isn't just addictive it stays
with you this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity hey only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy package of the
tetris can you get us the rights
the show Butte Union had worldwide
rights nothing gets out easily I'm gonna
go to Moscow you're walking into a
country they're still considers America
enemy Numero Uno okie dokie
sure you don't have to talk to your wife
about this first pioneers have to bet
the house to win but not literally
listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire mystologists have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
thank you
the most powerful men in government
started watching you and your family do
you know where your husband is what the
hell is going on the world is changing
and Soviet Union will not be left behind
you want to play with the big boys this
is how the world Works where is my money
this is insane we can't protect you
sometimes you gotta forget the rules
[Music]
go go
this is Criminal
Soviet Union is about to implode they're
lying everybody
recovery is coming we don't have time I
have a plan
oh come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
[Music]